tell me what do you want to say to your
fans accusations and rumors have swirled
for decades now al Kelly is formally
facing sexual abuse charges are you
innocent Robert Kelley was indicted
before at Cook County grand jury on ten
counts of aggravated criminal sexual
abuse involving four victims aggravated
criminal sexual abuse is a class 2
felony with a sentencing range of 3 to 7
years per count lawyer Michael avinasi
who is representing two Kelley accusers
says the charges stem from a tape he
gave to the prosecutors this tape leaves
no question as to whether our Kelley is
guilty of multiple sexual illegal acts
against a 14 year old girl today marks a
watershed moment in the 25 years of
abuse by this predator known as our
Kelly the charges come in a rising tide
of allegations against the singer on
Thursday two more women came forward
with their account of what happened
after an our Kelly concert they attended
as teenagers in the mid-1990s
high-profile women's rights lawyer
Gloria Allred is representing them to
our County I'm sending this message you
have nowhere to run and nowhere to hide
you have been able to get away with your
predatory misconduct for far too long 11
years ago our Kelly was acquitted after
facing child pornography charges
throughout the numerous accusations
spanning roughly 25 years he has never
been convicted always maintaining his
innocence many of the women who say they
were abused by Kelly also say they felt
ignored by the media and the authorities
the Power has always been his they say
they've waited a long time for that
balance to shift
Amanda Walker's Sky News Washington